ARTUR TSURKAN: Awesome.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Artur.
I'm a product manager
on Android system UI.
MADY MELLOR: I'm Mady.
I'm an engineer on
Android system UI.
JASON MONK: And I'm Jason.
I'm an engineer
on Android system.
ARTUR TSURKAN: And we're here
to talk to you about Android
slices and how you can use them
to build interactive results
for Google search.
So before we get
into the details,
I wanted to start by
answering the question of what
slices are?
And at a high level, slices
are Android's new approach
for remote content.
There's a couple of
important aspects to this.
The first is that
slices are templated.
What we mean by
this is that we are
going to provide you with
a flexible and rich mode
of expressing your app that's
also predictable and dependable
so that they can be presented
by a wide variety of surfaces.
Slices are also interactive.
These templates house
a variety of components
to enable anything from
rich content previews
to inline task completion.
And also, slices are updateable.
We're going to be able
to iterate much more
quickly than the traditional
platform releases
to enable new places for
these slices to appear
and new types of slices for
you to express your app.
Most importantly,
slices are backwards
compatible all the way back
to Android Kit-Kat, which
means that as they
launch, they're
going to be available for
95% of Android devices.
So let's dig into some of these
in a little bit more detail.
When we say slices
are templated,
we mean that we are providing
you with a rich layout
and content system to enable a
wide variety of app use cases.
These templates are
not plug and play.
They're flexible
in that you define
a wide variety of elements
and define them in a priority
order, so to enable a
rich variety of ways
to express your app.
Anything from a weather
forecast to a reservation, music
playlists to home automation.
And Mady's going to go
into a lot more details
on how you construct these.
Slices are also interactive.
They're not just static data.
They can house a variety
of components, anything
from real time data
fetched directly
from the APK on
a user's device--
for example, surfacing
the latest prices
for ride sharing--
as well as rich
controls, like actions,
toggles, sliders, and
scrolling content,
so that users can complete
the task inline right where
the slice is being presented.
Slices are bundled with Jetpack.
That means that we can more
frequently expand and iterate
slices.
That means we can add
more presenting surfaces
to expand your app's
reach, more templates
to represent your
app's use cases,
and more controls and
components to make
those slices more engaging
and more powerful for users.
Here's an example of a
potential new messaging template
that we're exploring
for the future.
So all this sounds pretty
great, but the really important
question is, where
are slices going
to be available for users?
Where are we launching?
This year, slices are
launching in search,
where we're going to use slices
to enhance app predictions
as the user is searching.
There are going to be two
main use cases in terms
of how slices will appear.
The first is for app names.
So as a user is searching
for the name of your app,
we'll be able to
surface what you
may call a canonical slice for
your app to help accelerate
some sort of task.
But we'll also support
general term searches,
so that users are able to
search for an app deep link
or a specific feature.
And of course, because slices
are backwards compatible,
when they start
appearing in search,
you'll be able to reach
all hundreds of millions
of users that are available
on Google search today.
This is really important,
because with slices, you're
going to be able to enable a
wide variety of really great
use cases for folks on search.
For example, here are a
couple of three buckets
that we are liking to share
to get your juices flowing.
The first is a
navigation use case.
This is in the
sense that the user
is searching for something
that they already
know they want to get to.
For example, the user
knows that they already
want to get a ride home.
Well, with slices, you
can use real time data
to provide additional
context for that decision
so that they know the price
and time to their destination.
And they can just start thinking
about booking their ride
right from the search results.
They also enable
inline task completion.
You might be able to use
those interactive controls
I was referring to earlier,
so that apps like settings
can enable users to quickly
search for a setting
and toggle it inline.
And finally, you can use slices
to enable recall and discover
use cases.
Users might be searching for
things that they didn't even
realize is available
in your app,
but because it's
installed on their device
and that you can
surface slices for it,
you might serendipitously
surface that content for them
to explore.
But this is only
just the beginning.
Our goal with
slices is to enable
one reusable API to generalize
remote content in Android.
And different things
that we're exploring
is trying to make
slices more tightly
integrated into the system, as
well as more Google platforms.
I'm going to hand it off to
Jason to talk a little bit more
about slices' architecture.
JASON MONK: Thanks, Artur.
Well, in a minute
Matt he's going
to walk you through actually
building your first slice,
but before that I
want to give you
a little bit of an
idea of how slices work
and how they look
under the hood.
So slices-- what a slice
actually is in terms
of implementation--
it's structured data.
And that structured data
contains other slices, content,
and presentational hints.
And so one thing to note,
this is not actually
code on the screen.
I know it looks
kind of like a DSL.
But this is really a
string representation
of what you would construct
once you're actually
done building a slice.
There are a few things
that we extract out
of this information.
The structure that it has
determines the template.
And like what we're
seeing, like this example
of a horizontal weather slice.
It also contains
the content itself--
icons, text-- pending
intents for interactivity.
And the other thing
to note is that this
contains all of the data for
the slice, no matter the format.
Mady's going to talk you
through all of the formats
that we have for
slices right now
and how we may add more
in the future, too.
But a single slice that
you return in your app
will actually hold
all of the formats.
And so on the right,
we have a short version
of that same slice.
And that is using
the exact same data
to present in a
different format.
All right, so how does apps
actually get a hold of slices
from your app?
So slices sit on top
of content providers.
Slice provider extends
a content provider.
Don't worry, we try to hide as
much of the content provider
as possible for you.
But there are a few really nice
things that come out of this
is that they are based on
top of content URIs, which
means you can have a wide
variety of slices hosted
from your app.
And when an app wants
to show your slice,
you'll get a callback
to [INAUDIBLE] slice
and you'll get a
URI and you'll get
to decide what content you
want to connect to that URI
and return it in that slice
that I just showed you.
But then they're interactive,
so you need to actually
be able to update that.
And the way that works is
through a notified change.
You send a standard content
provider notify change
on your slice URI.
And whoever is
presenting your slice
will know that it's
time to update,
and they'll give you
another callback.
And you can return
different data
that is dynamic and
changes in response
to whatever has happened.
All right, now, I'm
going to hand it over
to Mady, who's going to
walk you through building
your first slice.
MADY MELLOR: Thanks, Jason, for
that architectural overview.
I'm going to walk you through
an app creating this Wi-Fi slice
today, so we're going to
build a SliceProvider that
provides this Wi-Fi slice
that has this toggle.
And tapping the toggle
will turn Wi-Fi on and off.
And then the connected
state will change
based on the Wi-Fi state.
So the first thing
you've got to do
is define the SliceProvider
in your Android manifest.
As Jason mentioned,
slices are built
on top of content providers.
So similar to a
content provider,
you've got to define it here.
This lets the operating system
be able to find your slices.
Then you have to implement
your SliceProvider.
This SliceProvider handles
multiple slices here.
So we have a Wi-Fi
slice, an alarm slice,
and a nightlight slice.
So what will happen
when something is
trying to display your slice?
You might type in Wi-Fi
into Google search,
and it's going to do
some ranking stuff.
But Jason will go into
some details later.
And it'll map that search
term to a content URI.
And in our case, that content
URI will be this Wi-Fi path.
Based on that, we're going
to build a Wi-Fi slice.
So we'll jump into this method.
Slices start with list builders.
So list builder
accepts different kinds
of rows of content.
This Wi-Fi slice
is fairly simple.
It's a single row.
So we first start
with our list builder.
We build a row builder
based off of it.
We had the Wi-Fi title.
And then we kind of
do this weird thing
where we check if
Wi-Fi state is loaded.
Maybe it takes some
time for us to determine
whether Wi-Fi is
connected or not
and we need to do that
in the background.
In the meantime,
we're still going
to return a slice with the
content we intend to display,
but we kind of note that
this content is loading.
So the toggle-- we
don't know the state.
And the connected text, we don't
know whether we're connected
or not.
So these two pieces, we need
to indicate that they're
going to be loaded.
We do that just by passing null
and a Boolean on the builder
methods.
We then add that row to the list
builder and we build the slice.
So meanwhile, our Wi-Fi
state has been loading.
Maybe when this is done,
we got a call back to
on Wi-Fi state loaded.
We flip our flag.
And now, we need to let
the UI know to update.
So our Wi-Fi slice is
being displayed somewhere.
And it is our sad little loading
state with just the Wi-Fi text.
So we need to let it know to
update to get that subtitle
string and the
toggle action and we
do that with
ContentResolver, notifyChange
on the full content
URI for that slice.
So you'll get a call
to unbindSlice again.
It will be the same Wi-Fi URI.
You'll walk into your
buildWifiSlice method.
And this time, our
Wi-Fi stays loaded
so we can check whether
we're connected or not,
set that subtitle text, and
create our toggle action.
So this getWifiToggleAction is
going to create a slice action.
This is how we represent
actions and slices.
So the slice action basically
wraps the pending intent
and then takes some
extra information
to represent the action.
In our case, we want to
respond to someone tapping
on the toggle, so we need
to have a broadcast receiver
to receive that pending
intent and do some stuff
to update Wi-Fi state.
So we build our slice
action with that intent,
a label describing the action,
and then a Boolean value
representing whether
this toggle is on or off.
So in our case, the Wi-Fi state.
So when you tap on that toggle,
that pending intent gets sent.
You'll define a broadcast
receiver for your app
to handle this intent.
In our case, we need Wi-Fi
manager to update Wi-Fi state.
Something neat that slices
does for toggles is--
so if the Wi-Fi was on,
I tap on that toggle,
that pending intent
gets sent, we'll
attach the resulting state of
the toggle, this extra toggle
state, to that
intent so that you
can retrieve it and know what
the new state of the toggle is.
We'll use that to
update the Wi-Fi.
And then we're going to
notify our content URI,
so that any Wi-Fi
slices being displayed
know to update because
Wi-Fi state has changed.
So how do you test these?
Right now, we've got this
great tool slice viewer.
It allows you to input your
content URIs for your slices,
and then you can
preview your slice.
It'll display the slices
in different modes.
So as Jason mentioned, we
had that shortcut and then
larger templates.
So this tool will allow you to
exercise those different modes
that slices support.
And the getting
started guide is great.
I'd highly recommend it.
So that's kind of the summary
of creating a slice from an app.
You have your SliceProvider
in your manifest.
You implement it.
You map your content URIs
to the different slices
that your app supports.
And then you build them
and handle any events.
And of course, test.
OK, templates.
Slices has a really
great templating system.
We think it's pretty flexible.
And we hope that it'll be able
to support many of your app use
cases.
This is an overview of the
different row types we support.
So as I mentioned, everything
starts with list builder.
And list builder, you
attach different rows to it.
So this slide sort of shows the
different rows that we support.
And you see text, toggle,
sliders, progress bars,
different kinds of
grid layouts, and these
are all kind of flexible.
So nothing is enforcing
requirements of content,
so you can kind of pick and
choose how you use these.
So as mentioned, you add
these to list builder
and you can kind of
see in these layouts
how you can express your app
uniquely with the system.
So Wi-Fi slice here is composed
of just different types
of rows, supports
the toggle, it can
do a list of Wi-Fi networks.
Our reservation slice for
your upcoming trip in Seattle
gives you the
important information,
gives you a preview
of your rental,
and then check in,
checkout locations
using a big picture and then
a grid layout with two cells.
And then our music slice--
it's interactive.
You can favorite things.
You can control
your music from it.
It's scrollable.
So I hope that you can
see how your app use
cases could be represented
in our template system.
So multiple formats.
As Jason mentioned,
you provide a slice
with all of the data
we need to present
in these different formats.
We want slices to be able
to move across the operating
system in different spaces.
And they might need to shift
their form based on that.
So we're supporting
a short cut form,
which is just a small tappable
icon, a small slice, which
is the first row of
your slice generally,
and then a large slice,
which is all of the content.
So when you're building your
slice, keep that in mind.
Make sure you test
the different modes
so that the slice
displays how you
expect it to in these formats.
Things presenting slices
can also customize them.
So they've got some flexibility
with increasing font size,
changing the font style,
and maybe overriding
any colors that you set.
Because we want slices to sort
of feel at home in the surface
that they're being presented in.
So I'm going to walk
you through an example
to build this home slice,
which allows you to control
your temperature and see the
many video cameras that you
might have in your home.
So again, starts with
the list builder.
Here, we're defining
two slice actions
for turning the temperature
up and turning the temperature
down.
These just take a pending
intent, icon compat,
and then a label.
We create our row, we set
our title and subtitle,
add the two actions,
add the row to the list,
and then we've got that
top part of the slice.
So we'll do the second part now.
The camera snapshots.
Maybe we'll get
our data for this.
This is a grid row, so we'll
define a grid row builder.
And then for each
of the data elements
we're displaying in
these cells, we'll
add a cell to the grid builder.
And the cell will take an
image, title text, and text.
And these are
displayed in the order
that you add them
to the cell builder.
So if you want to
mix them up, they
don't need to be
image, text, text.
It could be text, image,
text, so again, it's flexible.
Add that grid row to the list.
And then you've
built your slice.
And Jason is going
to take it away
to describe how you can
get these slices appearing
in Google search.
JASON MONK: Thanks, Mady.
All right, so like
Artur said, we've
got two cases that we're
talking about for Google search.
These are both showing
up in predictions.
So you can tap on the search
bar, type a few characters,
and the user will be
interacting with your app
basically at that point.
One thing to note,
this is only for apps
installed on your device.
We aren't currently doing
anything with instant apps
or stuff from the cloud.
And these next few slides
are really just a preview.
We're going to be launching
all sorts of documentation
when we officially ship
this later this summer.
All right, so let's
talk through how
you do this for an app name.
There are two things you
really need to do in this case.
You need to link a specific
slice to your main activity
of your app.
That's the activity
that shows up
in launcher and the
activity with the name
that users will search for.
And you need to grant
some permissions.
So linking the activity is
actually really, really simple.
You just add one piece of
metadata into your manifest.
And that metadata
points at any slice
URI you want within your app.
And that's the URI
that you can expect
to get bound when the users
type in the name of your app.
You also need to grant
these permissions explicitly
to search and play
services, so that it
has access to read your slice
and display it properly.
We'll talk a bit more about
permissions in a little bit.
But these are basically
the lines of code
you need to do for a default
slice or an app slice.
OK, so the bit more broad
range of general terms--
this is a little bit
more complicated.
Another thing to note is
that ranking may vary,
is that search is going to try
to present whatever content is
best for the user, and
so you can't always
guarantee that your app
is going to be shown.
But that can be enhanced
with a bit of usage reporting
and stuff like that.
There are a few things
you need to do here.
This is based on top of
Firebase app indexing, which
is existing APIs.
You can go read about them.
We've got a link
on the next slide.
And you tie those Firebase
app indexing content directly
to a slice.
And so that will
let search you know
when it triggers that app
indexable that it should
be showing a slice for that.
So the way you do
that is, when you
are pushing your
app indexable, there
is some metadata you can tag.
There's new APIs on
app indexing that
will be launched
with this, which will
let you specify your slice URI.
Another piece of this is that
there's a little bit of content
validation.
So when you're
doing app indexing,
you need to specify
a content URL.
And that content you needs
to map to the same slice
that you're specifying
with your app.
It's just a linking
sort of system
to verify that you've got
the right content showing.
And so the way
that works is there
are two things you need to do.
One is you need to add an
intent filter to your provider.
These have been
supported, but are rarely
used in Android for some time.
These look very
similar to app linking,
if you're familiar with verified
app linking or app linking,
this will look pretty
similar to you.
This intent filter
is an example.
It's looking for anything on
https:example.com/anything.
If you don't have app
linking set up for your app,
you can do your own URL schemes.
Like in the settings
app in Android,
we're doing settings://--
whatever-- for our deep links.
And that's our URL scheme.
The other thing you
do is, once you've
added an intent filter
for your provider,
you can expect that you're going
to get calls to on map intent
to URI.
This lets your app say, I've
got some incoming intent data.
And intents are kind of squishy.
Intents aren't as
defined as a URI.
And this gives you
the moment to say,
here, I'm going to
take this intent
and I'm going to resolve
it to an exact URI
and this is the
slice I want to show.
And so you can do whatever
you want within this function
to determine your path.
In this case, it's just kind
of like taking the data off
from the intent and pushing
it over to authority,
which is a slice provider.
But you can add your own
logic of your own kind.
And that's how you add those.
All right, so that's
kind of a whirlwind tour.
I know.
We'll be launching more docs
with that when we officially
launch search.
Now, hopefully, your
slices are holding
all sorts of really
great content
and you don't want to expose
that content to the world.
So you probably
really care about how
the permissions work here.
So there are three
ways that an app
can get a hold of
permissions for your slice.
The first is you get fine
grained permission controls.
These are very similar
to URI permissions,
except we designed
them to scale up,
because we expect people to
have a lot of slices over time.
These happen
automatically for you
if you're using the
Firebase app indexing API,
as we just told you about.
We'll do those permission
grants for you.
You notice in the
default app slice,
you didn't have
that Firebase app
indexing, which is
why you had to grant
the permissions yourself.
The second case that is
different about these
from URI permissions is that
the user can grant permission.
When an app doesn't have
permission to show your slices,
the system will return what
we call a permission slice.
And it looks something like this
on the right, where it says,
hey, this app's trying to
show slices from someone else.
And the user can actually
explicitly grant.
And the third case of where apps
can get slice permissions is
that on P+, we're autogranting
permission to launcher
and the assistant to really
be able to do seamless kind
of slice integrations
in the future.
And so if the user clicks
on that permissions
slice that I mentioned,
they're going to see a dialogue
and they can choose either
to grant permissions
or not to grant permissions,
try to give them
some transparency as
to what's going on
and how they're exposing
data from your app.
So how does this work for you?
The way it works for you
is that you should extend
slice provider,
because you're going
to need to for everything.
And slice provider is going to
handle all of this permission
checking for you.
It's going to do all of it.
Please don't add
Android:permission
to your providers as you're
used to in your manifest.
That's going to
break everything.
And also, if you have a
really, really sensitive data,
if you're something like a
banking app and you feel like,
oh, no, users could really,
really shoot themselves
in the foot here, you can
override onCreate permission
request, and that will let
you disable the user grant
and redirect them to
some other dialogue.
You can have your own sort of
flow there to ensure privacy.
All right, and I'm going
to pass it back to Artur
to wrap things up.
ARTUR TSURKAN: Awesome.
So that was a lot
of information.
If you're interested
in learning more,
please go to this short
link, g.co/Slices.
In here is everything
related to our getting
started guide, as well as
links to use and download
the slices viewer,
building your first slice,
and all the details
that you need
to know about creating all the
rich templates that Mady talked
about.
We'll also be available today
and tomorrow at office hours.
That will be posted on
our thank you slides,
as well as the
Android sandbox if you
have any direct questions.
We also want to hear from
you, so please go to this
google.com/io/scheduling
to provide feedback on this
session.
But thank you all,
again, so much
for coming in the wee
hours of the morning
and hearing us
talk about slices.
As well, again, you can
follow these follow-up actions
to learn more.
We also have a bit
of time for questions
right now if anyone has anything
burning that they want to ask.
[MUSIC PLAYING]